it's funny because what I the way I
describe it is we had the analog age of
assets which is kind of up to ya know
80s maybe early 90s yeah then we went to
electronic age right and it's really the
electronic ages electronic assets kind
of an air quotes but just representing
yeah physical assets yeah now what
you're describing is digital native
asset yeah right it's kind of trite the
actual asset itself is digital there's
no physical representation totally yeah
I mean what what what most people don't
feel what most people don't realize is
that the US dollar is an Oracle database
running on a Sun Solaris machine in a
server at the Fed that is the US dollar
the US dollar is a single database the
the record is a single database and
payments are basically you know comma
delimited text files that are pushed
around on FTP servers on secure FTP
servers that's what ACH is that's what
Swift is so the the quote unquote
electronic money system is is an arcane
system that is decades and decades old
it's not modern it's not secure and it's
certainly not open and permissionless
which is obviously part of it and so
there has been the introduction of
software into the financial system but
money itself is not digital until crypto
you don't actually have truly digital
money that where the the the asset can
become a bearer instrument and it's and
it is you know not possible to copy
right this is the innovation of the
preventing double spending is you know
digital artifacts are incredibly
powerful mp3s were an incredibly
powerful digital artifact because you
could copy it the same song could
instantly be everywhere for free but
with money you don't want that you don't
want the same dollar to instantly be
everywhere for free so you know the that
was a huge part of the crypto
breakthrough is by plot you know applied
cryptography peer-to-peer networking
and of course fundamentally these very
very brilliant incentive structures we
now have money that is truly digital and
that it's not in a sequel database it
sits on a blockchain do you feel like
the server back to the US dollar example
I think the way you articulate it's
interesting cuz we basically we're
saying is look this old technology right
and just like every other piece of
technology you use you want the latest
and greatest right and and that
technology is not the latest and
greatest of what it could be
do you feel like there's risk in kind of
that central database specifically
around money right we I think a lot of
people talk about it from oh there's
centralized companies they have your
user data all of those types of things
but around money specifically is there
more less may be the same amount of risk
is let's say user data in a centralized
server environment how do you kind of
think about that yeah I mean it's
interesting on a number of levels I
guess you know Digital bearer
instruments are a new phenomenon we we
had you know we had bearer instruments
in the past and now we have these
digital bearer instruments and they're
more powerful than than the past right a
digital bearer instrument there's a much
higher threshold of security risk around
those you know hence the huge growth in
you know criminal attacks on people who
have crypto assets for example they
these bearer instruments can move at the
speed of the internet they can move in
or galactically you know they they have
some attributes that old bearer
instruments did not so it does create a
different set of risks and security
risks that are quite different than a
centralized money system I think it does
raise the question and this is where I
think you know there's a need for this
infrastructure and these assets for many
of them to be truly decentralized where
you can
in a self sovereign manner control it
but society will also demand and does
demand that there are trusted
intermediaries as well and so I think
you know companies like circle companies
like coinbase
I think are you know in that hybrid
world right where we are we're licensed
and regulated we you know behave more
like banks in some cases but we're
allowing people to interact with the
open permissionless Internet as well and
so trying to find that balance and if
people want to be their own bank and
they want to take those digital assets
and move them to a hardware device move
them to a brain wallet
move them to another venue they have the
freedom to do that so that freedom is
really really key and an important but
there is still this role for for
intermediaries we think as well and
governments will ultimately require that
as well yeah and part of it is the more
technical you are the less that you may
think you need something like that but
the vast majority of people on this
planet are not technical they definitely
need you know great user experiences
great interfaces great kind of
intermediaries right all of those things
actually increase the adoption and
increase the functionality for you know
again I don't know four five six billion
people who don't know how to write any
sort of software code yeah and and I
think in this world specifically where
it used to be you know I think of it as
like the Internet you hadn't understand
networking right and you can connect to
the internet and so you gotta be
somewhat technical but it was networking
yeah now it's much more software based
skills right and so if you don't have
that you need something to use and I
think that there's a lot of companies
that are trying to step in office he
circles done a great job doing that but
it's not only needed from a regulation
standpoint it actually increases the
value for everyone else everyone as many
people on board yeah clinical network is
absolutely yeah so I think that's really
part of the challenge going forward
people talk about like where's the
killer app there's lots of killer apps
right obviously self sovereign money
non-sovereign digital money that's a
pretty killer app and it's really
valuable to a lot of people I was just
reading an article today it was a story
out of Venezuela and there's a I think
it might have been from this New York
Times piece that came out recently but
there's a guy who who got his wealth
into Bitcoin and he was fleeing
Venezuela for Colombia and he was like I
don't want to take the risk of having a
USB disk I don't want to take the risk
of having a paper wallet so used to
brain wallet he memorized his seed
phrase and he walked across the border
and he brought all of his wealth with
him with a seed phrase in his brain like
that's awesome that's incredible that is
incredible and that is human freedom and
that's tremendous and that we have to
preserve that but like you said that's
not you know your average person is not
gonna memorize their seed phrase they
can't remember their password - gee I
think they need the option for that you
know and and so I think the key is you
know when people think about the killer
apps is whether it's sort of storing
value or making payments or seamlessly
investing in some investment contract
that happens to be a smart contract or
entering into an economic relationship
that's mediated by smart contracts all
of those things have to become as easy
as search or Gmail or you know your your
you know mobile messaging apps or they
just have to be that easy and
trustworthy at the same time and need to
give people the freedom to have complete
freedom as well and so that's the I
think the the balance that we need to
find I think that's the the balance that
we're trying to strike with products
that we're working on now is to be able
to kind of work across those spectrums
but like crypto isn't useful for
payments today it's useful in some cases
and there are some what I characterize
is mostly niche
use-cases today and it isn't so much
that it's about scalability or cost like
if if only we had lightning Network
everyone would make payments in Bitcoin
I don't believe that
I think lightning is useful as a as a
layer to technology for a lot of things
but I don't think it's gonna drive like
mass payment adoption you need Fiat
stable coins and or you know stable
coins more broadly and you need the user
experience of you know kind of funding
those taking funds out of those spending
those using those not require that you
have meta masks and know how to pay gas
fees to a smart contract which is just
simply inconceivable for the average
person right so there's just like a
threshold of usability that needs to
exist and again we're very very close on
some of these things and I hope that
circle can be a company to help solve
some of those along with a lot of others
in the industry but you know we're
getting there yeah I want to go back to
the early days of circle because I think
sure what a lot of people know you
forced today is not actually how I got
started
right and so maybe talk a little bit
about the first product you guys built
and the evolutions are you you know this
kind of multi strategy or multi product
company today yeah absolutely I'll go
through that narrative so you know the
first thing that we built was we knew we
want to build a kind of new type of kind
of almost like global bank so the first
thing that we built was a platform so we
built platform infrastructure that we
built a transaction banking system we
built an identity and risk system and we
built a settlement system that could
seamlessly move between the legacy
banking system and crypto rails and that
was really key because the first product
that we wanted to create was a payment
product and we wanted to create a way
where people could use fiat currency
with any bank account in the US and
Europe which was the initial target and
seamlessly moved Fiat value over the
Bitcoin network and our concept was that
we would use Bitcoin as a settlement
network
and we would essentially marshal or move
Fiat in and out of that very quickly and
so that was actually the first product
that we built and it works it absolutely
worked in actually people who were who
wanted to use Bitcoin really loved it
because it actually turned into one of
the cheapest fastest ways to get Bitcoin
but there were challenges with it which
is that Bitcoin as a settlement rail had
a lot of issues transaction time the
number of confirmations volatility you
know and and volatility continued to be
significant and cost I mean the
transaction fees tended to get so slow
expensive and price volatile so as a
like intermediate kind of settlement
currency and settlement network it
didn't work as an open network it was
great so the idea was that our digital
wallet would work with any other digital
wallet because we were all speaking the
Bitcoin protocol so there were
challenges with with what we built and I
think one of the challenges was we
wanted to have this like incredibly fast
seamless experience where you could just
like connect any debit card and with
very little information just instantly
be transacting with this and that was
really attractive to fraudsters really
attractive to cyber criminals and I
think was you know I think very
challenging for our banking partners and
our card scheme partners who you know I
think it was running up against the
limits of of what they were comfortable
with so we put a pause on using the
Bitcoin network and began work at the
time on something called spark which
became US dollar coin and I'll come back
to that but one of the things that
happened in the interim was in order to
create that circle pay that product we
built a Treasury and trading operation
where we managed real time liquidity
between fiat and crypto and so we built
out this kind of both automated trading
engine and then as the customer demand
grew a desk where we kind of source
liquidity to handle all this customer
volume so we ended
building one of the most efficient
connected trading platforms for Bitcoin
and so starting in 2014 that started to
grow 2015 and continued to grow 2016 it
really started to grow and by 2017 was a
huge business and so our second product
is circle trade which is our market
making an OTC service emerged out of the
infrastructure that we built for
payments and its original design was to
support that payments infrastructure and
then we saw like ok this is actually a
great service in and of itself so we
really allowed that to grow and then in
the summer of 2017 obviously during this
sort of dramatic growth in icos and and
all and and so on we like I think others
became very very excited about
tokenization and we thought you know we
very much thought that in the coming
years that you know tokenized
economic contracts tokenized financial
contracts would become a much much
bigger thing and we were seeing kind of
in the crypto exchange market kind of
the early examples of what like a token
marketplace could be and so we got to
know the Polonia acts founders really
well because they were a client of ours
with circle trade makes sense and they
happen to be from Boston we were in
Boston so we spent more time together
and it became pretty clear that you know
they needed help the business was
growing extremely fast and they needed
help with technology operations support
compliance risk regulatory you name it
like they it was a very small very small
team and and they did not have a lot of
experience like scaling out things so
from our perspective you know Polonia X
was actually a really great company
because they were at the forefront of
working with developers who were
launching new projects and helping
create the markets for those
and you know that kind of being a place
a marketplace where you're bringing
these kinds of new tokenized projects
into the market it was a really unique
early position and our long-term vision
is we think there's going to be mass
proliferation in tokenized assets we
think there's going to be you know far
far greater numbers of stable coins with
multiple currencies we think there's
going to be you know significant
multiple significant store value privacy
focused digital currencies we think
there's going to be proliferation in
utility tokens that are used to power
crypto networks and encrypted apps so
going from you know maybe dozens of
meaningful utility tokens today to
thousands and then in last but not least
we're very big believers in the idea
that financial contracts equity like
debt like property like financial
contracts will be tokenized and we
believe though we very large multi-sided
markets that are similar to internet
markets we have four other things to
enable those to enable people to issue
those and enable people to exchange
those and so for us acquiring Polonia
acts was not just you know hey let's
acquire this exchange that has all these
people trading digital currencies it was
this is a foundation and a building
block to a much bigger long-term vision
and so we've now kind of completed you
know roughly a year of transforming the
infrastructure to be ready for this
broader vision that we have providing
you know much stronger kind of security
protocols you know our own custody
infrastructure for it D risking the
platform and putting in place of
framework for curating the markets
selecting projects to launch and have
now really started to do that much more
proactively one question I have about
Polonius and I think everyone talks
about the technology in crypto and it is
very focused on what I'll call it more
hard skilled type stuff but there's some
soft skills stuff that a lot of these
companies
217 suffered from pretty drastically
yeah right so customer support the
regulation type stuff
and some of it I think is any company
that goes from very number a very small
number of customers to a lot there's
just you gotta hire people you got you
know there's those types of like scaling
issues and then some of it is even if
you have all the people you start to
know what to do how to do it right the
things to focus on not focus on etc I
think Polonia acts when you guys made
the acquisition the general sentiment
was oh wow here's a group of
entrepreneurs that have success building
internet companies have scaled things
I've taken them public there was a lot
of people who liked the technology in
the exchange and they felt like this was
a great merging of you know that
technology and had some issues right
around support and all that but you guys
were gonna be able to help you know they
kind of do that it was pretty quick you
could see the sentiment of people say
wow like it's actually getting better
right and and obviously I think the you
guys did a bunch of stuff in the
background do you think that there are a
bunch of other companies that suffered
from that in 2017 where they would be
unable to do that themselves and they're
gonna need these big you know kind of
I'll call the crypto incumbents to step
in and really help with that yeah or do
you think that this is something where
they just need a lot more time and even
money and they'll be able to build it
out and if there's another bull run like
we saw they'll be ready for that but do
you think that consolidation is
essential or do you think that we can
stay with some kind of fragmentation and
let those young companies really kind of
grow into their own I think it's it's
it's very much both okay I think it
depends on the specific problem space
but I mean beautiful thing about
software and entrepreneurship is you
know there's just this constant kind of
fount of new idea creation and
development and the kind of laboratories
where that happens aren't always in
large companies and you know I think the
internet and cloud software and you
open source and distributed development
all of these things make you know
innovation that easier in some ways or
and and faster and can move it a greater
velocity I think I think there's me a
lot of projects that will will grow and
scale and they don't have to be
consolidated etc I think there are
others that will
will need to be consolidated and there's
plenty that are just gonna peter out
which is very natural so i don't i don't
think it's a it's an either/or or
something like that it'll be interesting
to see over the next few years in
particular in in the kind of these the
markets space as the market space very
likely does require more regulatory
capability and the opportunities to kind
of do regulatory arbitrage get smaller
and smaller i think that will that will
force a lot of players out or to be
consolidated but that'll take some time
yeah
i tend to agree with you on this idea
that every stock bond currency commodity
is gonna get digitized or tokenized over
time one thing that you guys did after
you moved from the bitcoin rails and the
ability to kind of transact money was
you created a stable coin right if we
talked a little bit about kind of the
thought process to create your own how
you thought about actually keeping it
stable there's a bunch of different
options there yeah and then what you
guys are doing with the with it today
sure so kind of going back to the the
first thing that we worked on which was
how do we take fiat money and use public
blockchains as the settlement
infrastructure for fiat money that was
the problem we wanted to solve and our
belief back then was that if you could
do that in a standardized way then
digital wallets everywhere in the world
could just be interoperable with each
other and it would be more like the web
or email we'd have this sort of this
seamless ability to transact with people
instantly but still with the price
stable value of the
everyday currency right so that was what
we originally set out to do our view
back then and our view still now is that
that there have to be actual open
technical standards that people can
follow there has to be a protocol and a
set of standards that people can
contribute to that are open for for that
purpose and so we began work we started
work on the technology for stable coins
as early as early 2017 and then in late
2017 we announced that we were forming a
project called Center which was going to
be an open standard and an open
open-source implementation of a kind of
fiat payment model not a lot of people
pay too much attention at the time but
then in in the summer we announced the
kind of first milestone of Center which
was the the first the first
implementation which is the US dollar
token and the US dollar coin now Center
was created as a membership-based
consortium so it's not it's not circle
it's not coin base its center and center
exists to define the technical standards
for fiat money on the Internet to define
the self governance framework for people
who become issuers of that fiat token
and that's really important that there's
a set of standards it's almost like a
self regulatory framework for companies
that are going to issue these and the
key is that this is a protocol where the
issued tokens are fungible right I want
to be able to use my US dollar coin if I
got it from circle I want to be able to
redeem it with coin base or redeem it
with another issuer and so this is
really key is that you have that
interoperability and fungibility
especially with money is is really core
so we've taken that approach which is
very unique and now circle and coinbase
are launched you know as issuers and
and we were taking a big step towards
that so the you know the the concrete
details are you know US dollar coin is a
asset-backed fiat asset backed stable
coin customers can from eighty countries
send funds from a bank account and
they'll be tokenized into US dollar
coins we hold a hundred percent of the
funds that they've sent to us in reserve
so it's a one to one asset backed token
and we prove that every month one of the
largest auditing firms in the world
Grant Thornton does a monthly published
at a station they review of the bank you
know accounts and they review the issued
and in in circulation tokens and they
published that at a station and it's
grown very fast so it is now I think a
really powerful way to move value on and
off of the blockchain and it has great
liquidity it's you can redeem it and
anytime for a dollar which is the whole
point so it actually is redeemable
you're not like worrying about some
weird opaque offshore bank accounts that
are always changing or sometimes you can
get Redemption or sometimes you can't or
it's it's really straightforward very
transparent and you can use it and
because it's an ER c20 token it's got
incredible compatibility already so I
think like 120 companies or some huge
number of companies already support it
wallets exchanges custodians a lot of
the dphi companies that are out there
are using it as their US dollar
mechanism whether as a collateral
mechanism or paying it out in loans and
so it's it's really become very very
useful and it's it's now I think within
the market making community considered
sort of best-in-class as a way to move
dollar value around because they can
actually it's actually liquid you
so it's it's been a very good early
success and I think we have you know we
have a lot of ideas for where it can go
and so originally wrote we're in this
piece I was talking about JP Morgan they
just now is this new GPM coin they've
basically come out and said look we're
gonna use it internally they're not the
first or I think silver gate banks been
moving money around internally on a
blockchain HSBC's been moving money
around on their own internal blockchain
they said I think they moved like two
and fifty billion last year doing this
one of the things that I wrote about and
to me the concern is much more with the
incumbent Wall Street banks is they come
out and they say okay I have a fiat
backed digital currency right so the US
dollar or JPM coin they use it
internally then they get institutional
adoption with peers and with clients
they then push into retail and people
start using it there and then at some
point they very similar to in 1971 with
the US dollar they basically say we're
actually going to break the peg right we
are going to come off of that US dollar
backing and essentially what they do at
that point is they become a central bank
right they can print that will their
digital cut the JPM coin and it feels
like it's a really dangerous thing so I
mean that scenario I don't think is
likely okay this what I want to talk
about yeah like talking well the reason
is that they're they're a Federal
Reserve regulated Bank
okay there's reserve requirements and
there's Basel 3 which is a global
standards for the health of a balance
sheet and and what level what amount of
leverage you know all banks their core
business model is creating money that's
what they do
yep money's not created by central
bank's money is created by bank banks
and I love that yeah I mean that's what
they do they get a deposit and then they
create ten more units or whatever the
ratio is from that one deposit they
create money based on a deposit that
they have with the hope with the risk
that the people who they've given that
money to on credit will ultimately pay
them back right so that's it's a high
it's a leveraged business
and it's a money creation business
that's the very core of what banking is
so would a JPM want to be able to do
fractional reserve of course because
that's their that's their core business
model I mean that's the very essence of
banking so that's not so much breaking
the peg that's just doing their business
I think they would not be permitted to
go beyond the reserve requirements that
they have as a bank it's an ability
provision of the federal government and
under supranational schemes like Basel
which basically governments have signed
on to and a legislative capacity and
those are the reserve requirements that
exist for banks everywhere so you know
that's that's the law and so I don't see
them going outside of that it does raise
the question of at what point are things
like asset-backed or Fiat back to stable
coins fractional if I'm a bank and I'm
and I'm issuing a stable coin token I
absolutely want to be able to do it on a
fractional reserve basis because that's
what I do for a living mm-hmm yeah
that's really interesting I think the
example I gave is probably the extreme
right we just completely break what
you're describing is there is probably
going to be some you know ability for
them to do it on a fractional reserve
basis up to a limit that is governed in
some way do you see issues with the
fractional reserve side and I firmly
haven't thought about enough to have an
opinion here where it's a pretty well
understood business model that we've
kind of seen what some of the risks are
how that plays out in traditional
fractional reserve scenarios so it
deposits money or and they lend it out
when you get to this asset back digital
currency like if there's a fractional
reserve mechanism there do you foresee
that being problematic do you think that
it fits very similar to the traditional
business right how do you look at that
yeah it's a it's an interesting one I
mean I think one of the one of the
potentially attractive things about
central bank digital currency is
the possibility that you know the the
central you know the central bank has
has in a sense better visibility into
the underlying health of the financial
institutions so if you take the
financial crisis as an example the the
the bank regulators they had no idea
what we're in these balance sheets right
the the the quote-unquote integrity of
the balance sheets and whether or not
they were you know healthfully leverage
or leveraged according to the kind of
safety and soundness requirements they
didn't know and the bank's didn't know
either and so the the theoretical
question would be if fiat money if
credit if derivatives if securities were
all you know digital tokens and mediated
by smart contracts and block chains
could regulators have dramatically more
visibility into the health of the
economy and the health of any given
financial intermediary and in theory
they could now they're they're sort of
privacy questions and they're sort of
ways that you'd have to think about kind
of these are you know people talk about
proof of reserves with like you know
crypto balances well you can imagine if
your full stack of the financial system
is built with crypto assets and block
chains and that takes on a whole new
meaning so I think that it actually in
some ways crypto you know crypto assets
tokenized assets tokenized fiat things
like this have the potential to not only
support the existing model for banking
but but also make it significantly safer
and safer to to monitor from a you know
a risk perspective yeah so I think
you know I was actually just with a
giant global auditing firm and you know
they're really passionate about public
blockchains
and the idea that you know as more and
more even like corporate Treasuries move
to tokenized assets then it could really
transform the way in which you can audit
right yeah I mean look a blockchain is
basically just a new accounting
mechanism right and it's for the digital
world so I look at it and so if you are
an accountant or you are an audit firm
and you can figure out how to leverage
this it should give you an advantage of
what you do today for sure yeah you know
one of the things I wanted to maybe
ladder off that on and talk about is you
know people talk a lot about security
tokens and we're we're very interested
in that as well as you know with the
acquisition that we've done and I think
you know what's interesting to me is
mistake for word thing would be to say
hey I've got some Delaware shares can I
talk in eyes those and now they're you
know they're shares on the blockchain or
they're tokenize shares etc and I think
there's good reasons to do that I think
that there's a whole bunch of benefits
you get from that but the more
interesting question is is what is a
natively digital corporation and what
does it mean to have the the voting the
governance the corporate Treasury all be
based on crypto assets and all be
intermediated by tokenized contracts and
you know it becomes possible to think
about the the governance the voting the
ownership the treasury functions which
then in turn has to do with you know
everything from payroll to how you
interact with businesses and so a lot of
the building blocks for building an
actually an entirely digitally native
corporation that's all built on public
chains is emerging and that's what's
interesting to me is not so much like
how do we create a Delaware
c-corporation
you know you take the jurisprudence of
Delaware and you put some thin layer of
that into a smart contract again I think
that's really powerful and interesting
the long term though is you know there's
obviously platforms like Aragon which
are really trying to push this of these
decentralized autonomous organizations
and trying to build those functions
entirely in that way and I think we're
probably a ways off from that being
something that a global auditing firm
would say yeah that's a that's a we get
that but I think it you know when we
think about the the real disruptive
potential it's that micro economic
organizations the micro economic units
of organization could be entirely run in
software and be inherently automatically
global and have economic relationships
that are inherently automatically global
and that's extremely powerful and and
certainly where we'd like to see things
what you're talking about here that
there's a gentleman who who briefs to
give me this example and I thought it
would perfectly articulated it was the
publishers when they first saw the
Internet right so me take a newspaper
publisher they see the Internet and they
say oh my god I can now take my physical
paper sure I can basically scan it onto
the internet and there's a website and
anyone in the world can go read the
newspaper I'm not the most physical cops
the PDF version and everyone was super
excited about that and there's value
right look you you can absolutely give
it a more people and all that stuff but
it missed out on the ability to do
dynamic headlines update articles you
know distribution all these things that
we now know is meat as digital media
yeah it took a while for people to
understand here's what this internet
thing can do and how to actually
leverage it yeah what you're describing
is almost exactly the same right the
kind of initial ideas around tokenized
securities is take what we have put it
on a rack chain right and and just value
right you know it just doesn't tap into
the full potential to acquire seedinvest
you've now closed that so one
congratulation thank you but to maybe
just talk a little bit about you
why do you go do that and to how do you
see their platform kind of positioning
you well for that world that you just
described yeah absolutely very related
so so you know in our vision we believe
that more and more you know businesses
are going to be able to you know
directly raise capital on the internet
and raise capital from Main Street
investors from institutional investors
from investors all around the world and
that the the capital assets that they
raise will be increasingly become more
liquid and tradable and that there's a
tremendous opportunity to transform
capital formation and private capital
markets more broadly so we think what's
happening with crypto is part of that
and in a lot of people's minds they're
they're sort of like oh there's this
weird cryptocurrency trading thing over
here and then there's like the stock
market over here we actually see a lot
of convergence but you know right now
today you know there there is no global
marketplace for private capital for
private financial contracts doesn't
exist and I would I would sort of have
you think about it similar to the retail
world or the media world or the
publishing world pre-internet right in
the retail world like you you had to
have a pretty good scale to be able to
have distribution and to reach a lot of
people with your product it was hard but
you know platforms like eBay and then
the Amazon Marketplace the Alibaba
marketplace is just as examples made it
possible for anyone who's creating any
product anywhere in the world to reach
anyone and they were commerce platforms
logistics platforms it just blew it open
and and the the model of centralization
and retail was was kind of torn down I
think the same thing with advertising
right if you were someone who gave
tennis lessons in US
whatever it was it was inconceivable for
you to be able to run targeted
advertising that would reach exactly the
right people and they could be from
anywhere in the world and you know
AdWords created a massive efficient
global market for for advertising and
you see this in in other areas and
publishing and content and video we're
participating in that right now with
this podcast in terms of radio and I
think the same thing is very much
possible for for for entrepreneurs and
for people building businesses and and
by that I don't just mean like your
classic like tech startup that might do
like seed VC type money I'm talking
about someone is a land owner in an
emerging market that has yield from
their land and they have no way to
securitize that and participate in a
global capital market it's impossible
but it should be possible just like the
person that you know makes you know
plastic you know things or or makes
custom scarves in Bangladesh can sell on
Alibaba and reach a global audience it
should be possible for the financial
contracts that help businesses grow and
even individuals over time when you
think about the tokenized you know
future value of labour or other things
it should become possible for that to be
expressed in a digital form to be
discoverable and distributable through
global marketplace and to make the you
know economic actors be able to
participate more freely in that so
that's that's what we think becomes
possible seed invest is a great a great
addition to the circle family we're
really excited to have Ryan and James
and the team there joining us for folks
that aren't familiar they really were at
the forefront of creating ways for
businesses to raise capital directly on
the internet using equity and
crowdfunding models they helped put
together the JOBS Act they helped get it
through Congress
they helped FINRA and the SEC as the
exemptions got defined for that and they
were among the very first companies to
be launching
you know direct internet fundraising
models for businesses they've got a nice
business that grew you know very nicely
last year is profitable and and it
really gives us a great capability so
they have a service where if you're a
startup and you want to raise capital
you can go through their platform and
they will underwrite your your capital
raise they'll do an offering that can be
you know managed with both accredited
investors and unaccredited investors and
international investors they handle all
of the investment marketing they handle
the fulfillment the payment the getting
the securities held they have a custody
model for those securities and they've
really created this this kind of capital
formation engine and and they've got
kind of an end-to-end service for that
that fits really nicely with what we see
is the future of finance right this
democratization of Finance how can more
and more companies go digitally native
issue securities directly on the
internet from a broad range of investors
and and ultimately also have the
secondary markets for those as well
so seedinvest really really helps us
march towards that vision the kind of
digital security piece of this or the
security token piece of this that piece
as you know is more nascent there are
experiments in it I know you guys have
have been involved in some of those and
and frankly you know the SEC is still
getting their head wrapped around this
and so there aren't like a whole bunch
of registered security tokens that are
out there it's it's it's still I think
there's a lot of heavy lifting to
ultimately get to standards and kind of
agreement with regulators on how that's
all gonna work we'll be right there
working with them to make sure it works
in is feasible from a technology
perspective and ultimately from a market
perspective but that's that's sort of
the next big heavy lift is to really
really make sure that things like the
JOBS Act
the benefits of raising capital over the
Internet can also get the benefits of
cryptocurrency technology blockchains
digital securities because I think you
know it's interesting because Jake late
and he's really passionate about how do
we make private capital markets more
open how do we allow growing businesses
better access to capital how do we let
Main Street investors participate in
that he's you know how do we open up
private capital markets which globally
is massive and it needs to be
transformed and it I think it actually
ends up that you know crypto assets and
block chains are the way that we're
gonna do it so I just don't think J's
realized that yet what do you think an
aspect of this that took me a long time
to wrap my head around but now I have
started to gain confidence and I just
don't know when it happens or if the
regulator's are thinking about this yet
one of the promises of all this digital
securities blockchain et cetera is that
you could write the law or the
regulations into the code right and and
so the the general thesis here is if I'm
the SEC today you and I do something
that is breaks the regulation they've
got to come figure out who we are what
we did they build a case they spend
millions of dollars right in one or two
years then they enforce on us so they're
very reactive to us doing something that
is now and or outside of regulations if
the code is written into the law and you
and I try to do something that we might
even mean to do something that breaks
the regulation the code could actually
stop the transaction right and and be
internal regulator into a proactive
player in the marketplace one is there's
a bunch of technical stuff that he still
needs to be figure out to I think is
would that hold up in a court of law and
you know there's all that kind of stuff
that goes into it but I'm more
interested in the regulator's
perspective right I think that
technologists generally believe in this
macro trend of automation and kind of
efficiency gained from technology I just
don't have insight into the regulator's
approach to that type of stuff right and
so we see them public comments are very
encouraging of we want to encourage
innovation we want to open private
markets do you think that they've gotten
that far yet or kind of any insights
there as to how you think they maybe
should be thinking
about this idea of writing the Londa
code yeah I mean I I certainly think
that there's discussions happening
around some of those topics it's it's
not a coincidence that in the past five
years the the concept of reg tech has
emerged as a thing as fair reg tech
startups and they're all trying to sell
tact regulators to help with automation
and you know or to help companies who
comply with regulations and used to be
like compliance was like a software
category but reg tech is a category and
I think there's something there
obviously I think but this this issue of
you know essentially writing the law
into the code I think that's real I
think it's just it's gonna it's gonna be
very incremental right we're gonna start
with you know effectively like the share
certificate number and the accreditation
investor ID transfer restrictions like
this kyc AML yeah this sort of shim on
top of it but the real security is like
let's actually take a look at those
governance docs and take a look at what
requires votes and what are the votes
and what are the bylaws and what are the
classes of stock and what are all of the
mechanisms that exist to protect
preferred investors versus common and
all these kind of provisions and you
know those things will take a lot longer
to actually get into code and ultimately
it's only beneficial if they're
recognized if those things are
recognized by a court and so in some
ways this isn't I think going to come
down on high we're all of a sudden you
know the SEC or someone says yeah you
can do you can have a full all of the
terms of a security written in code it's
going to come from case law it's going
to come from an issue coming out with a
company and a court saying this is this
is allowable or it's going to come from
states passing laws like Delaware did
originally just to say you could keep
your your cap table records on a
blockchain but it'll be you know states
because ultimately these corporations
are domiciled in States or
as it were passing laws that basically
say you know the for example a vote on a
change of control could be effectuated
using you know votes conducted on a
blockchain using tokens that have been
issued to do these sort of shareholders
and that that's okay that that counts
just like you know a DocuSign now counts
for sure so I think some of that will
come through kind of case law and things
like that
how does some of this stuff change on
the regulation licensing and legal front
when it becomes decentralized so
decentralized organizations desensitised
exchanges what's kind of your thoughts
there around some of that yeah I mean
it's one of the most fascinating
dimensions to all of this is you know in
a world where you as a economic actor
choose to interact entirely with a code
based organization you know you you have
the free will to do that and you know so
long as you understand that that is what
you're interacting with I think it'll be
interesting to see whether some
governments at some point sort of assert
themselves saying well if you're an
individual or you're a business and
you're interacting with one of these
things here's your obligations or here's
our rights I haven't seen that happening
yet but I think you know my general take
on a lot of this stuff is that you know
the Internet has shattered existing
regulatory frameworks for decades and
you know people people probably forget
that you know if you wanted to you know
broadcast an audio conversation to
someone in Italy you needed a license
from the Italian government well the
internet came and guess what we can all
broadcast to everyone everywhere and we
don't need a license and in a sense when
these decentralized infrastructures
reach scale generally speaking people
like it it's
it's a better world and I think in a in
a world decentralized finance people and
businesses are gonna say we like this
this is a better world and it gives us
more control it's less expensive we can
move faster we get all these we you know
rent seekers dissipate and we get more
value and I think you know when billions
of people are gonna be able to interact
with each other and with with and with
you know through economic contracts
seamlessly over the internet no one's
gonna want to go back and so I think
that is just gonna require governments
to adapt and that's not to say that
there aren't still going to be
obligations around protecting consumers
or obligations around money laundering
or you know these are important kind of
social contracts that exist but the way
that those are the take shape may really
change so I think with some of these
things like just decentralize autonomous
organizations you know there will be
there will be some doubts that come
along that become really big and
successful and potentially have the
equivalent of tens of thousands of
quote-unquote employees but who have
only an interaction with a smart
contract and who are generating income
and maybe maybe the income still taxable
and reportable in their home
jurisdiction but the the software is
just a piece of software is that a
corporation no well so it's like the
Bitcoin network right with it with minor
so I guess if you think about it there's
no company that's paying there's an
algorithm that's governing yeah so these
resources I think so I mean I think I
think crypto networks that are
effectively dows in a sense it's just a
new form of human social and
technological organization it hasn't
existed before it exists now it's very
powerful those will grow there'll be
more and more of them they'll be very
very big and that that's that's positive
like that's positive for society and
humanity and again I think ultimately
when things become really positive it's
hard for governments to take them away
from people it's like it'd be very very
hard for God
to say we're taking away the internet
right even countries that have you know
censorship on the internet or that
filter for things they still like
they're not taking away the internet
because the Internet is so powerful that
would be just like such a monumental
step backwards for any given society
well in in the part that's always been
so interesting to me is take you know
Bitcoin for example there's there would
be a rational argument you could make
that hey if this decentralized digital
currency becomes the global reserve
currency there would be material impact
on a number of countries around the
world right and there would be reason to
believe that they wouldn't want that to
happen right
there's no CEO there's no headquarters
to go it's it's this decentralized thing
and so not only can they will they not
take it away because of the power and
all the stuff yeah but even if they said
we want to take it away it would have a
really hard time kind of putting the
genie back in the bottle yeah and and
that's not to say like kind of anarchist
view you know through the government
it's just more of what happens when
that's a corporation yeah right what
happens when that's something out late
like you get into a world that again
it's just a lot to think about you
haven't seen it before yeah I mean I
think some of the most ambitious
projects are you know decentralized
algorithmic stable coins and and again
none of them have really taken hold and
gotten scale but clearly there will be
there will be some and and that even
have a pegging mechanism to a basket of
fiat currencies so you could imagine a
global digital currency unit that's
algorithmically pegged to the major
economies of the world which is runs
entirely decentralized and kind of has
its own internal market structure to it
that is just code that allows anyone to
have a stable global digital currency
that's instantly convertible into any
any fiat currency that that is
absolutely on the horizon and really
really powerful and more powerful than
say a Bitcoin in my view because oh why
is that well because every day
you know everyday transactions people
need a price stable asset and and so I
think you know if you're if you're
looking at like a hedging asset or a
long-term store value asset Bitcoin is
very attractive but for everyday
economic activity you really need you
really need price stable assets that are
really tied to to stable economies and
the currencies of stable economies
that's how we're gonna transact that's
when we decide to enter into a
three-year bond contract with someone
it's gonna have to be denominated in
price stable assets be insane otherwise
you can't price risk you can't price
credit you can't you you you really
can't do anything
so either you know something like
Bitcoin gets so broadly adopted that its
price stable which I think you know by
design I think we're probably decades
and decades away from that mmm-hmm
yeah it's really interesting to think
through some of these solutions our
short-term medium-term and long-term
solutions and you know I always talk
about Venezuela for example so a lot of
people always say oh you know that
that's where bitcoins taking hold and
there's data that suggests that there
are plenty of people who are running to
Bitcoin but if you're a Venezuelan and
you want to walk across the border like
the example you gave earlier and all you
want to do is preserve your wealth right
you're not looking for an investment
opportunity use you're saying I don't
want to lose Ernie
owning US dollars will be a great option
so things like US dollar coin exactly
are potentially really attractive
everywhere in the world and and a brain
wallet works for you know ERC 20 tokens
to know this is it's not specific to
Bitcoin it was funny I just came back
from Asia and and it was interesting
just meeting with different folks and
you know I think there's a lot of
passion for US dollars and you know US
dollar markets in Asian economies are
really really highly valued
and you know US dollar or stable coins
are really really attractive all the way
down to the individual as well as like
the wealthy right so you know it's I
think one one thing that's a little bit
unknown is will we see surging growth in
stable coin you know Fiat stable coin
adoption as effectively a way for people
to to protect and and move value
offshore and it seems like that is a
very real thing and when you look at the
sort of offshore or offshore capital
markets offshore currency it's quite
large globally and and stable quentin's
become in some ways even better than
some of the alternatives yeah it's so
interesting the you know look being a
citizen in the United States you know
many people working on technology being
born in the United States there's a very
there's a lot of benefit set and then
there's some disadvantage to it right
you kind of come from a very Western
centric mindset and one of the things
that I've really try to do is travel as
much as I can because you just get a
different version of the world right and
some of you agree with some you don't
and you can't you know end up somewhere
in between but the one thing that I see
a lot of american-born entrepreneurs
specifically miss is just how big the
rest of the world is right like only 330
million people and yes the United States
has a lot of you know economic activity
etc yeah the places like India or China
or just it's almost impossible to
comprehend how much bigger they are then
in the US sure you look at like you know
Indonesia I think it's like 600 million
people you're like what crazy yeah and
everyone there has a need for a price
table currency absolutely yeah yeah yeah
you know the the internet and this is
one of the this is one of the things
that got me into crypto in the first
place which was holy cow like if you can
blow out how money is stored and moved
globally and make it usable to the
average smartphone user it can be really
radically transformative and I think
when you add this new layer of you know
contracting and economic contracting
that people who have these you know
digital money can interact with then it
becomes incredible because you can now
basically start to reconstruct economic
relationships all around the world
you know over the internet with fewer
intermediaries and that's the really
really transformative piece it's not
just about remittance or moving money
around it's about actually entering into
economic relationships and being able to
do that in a in a way where you don't
have to take counterparty risk where you
can have the trustworthiness of the
finality and security of the blockchain
in an economic relationship that's
profound mm-hmm absolutely before I wrap
up I always ask a couple of rapid-fire
questions sure what do you think is the
most important company in crypto can't
say circle the most important company in
crypto
I think right now it's the etherium
developer community Oh interesting okay
explain well aetherium right now has the
most adoption as a blockchain platform
that you can build apps on and smart
contracts on and the etherium developer
community not just the people developing
the core of the theorem but the broader
aetherium developer community to me are
like the forefront of developing this
new kind of crypto economy there are
really exciting new blockchain projects
that are looking to compete with the
theorem replace it but no one has yet
and you know these kinds of platforms
get built when you've got you know broad
developer adoption and people
contributing as well so I think it's
most important because if the etherium
community both core developers and the
broader developer community can get
through their scaling kind of challenges
then it represents probably you know
really tremendous breakthrough for
everybody mm-hmm okay what do you think
is the one regulation that you would
improve or change if you could you know
I think the what I'd like to see is
clarity in major jurisdictions on the
differences between kind of crypto
currencies crypto commodities utility
tokens and security tokens and so it's
really the the classification and in
particular with with security tokens I
think it's very important that
governments create definitions for how
these can be launched and used without
just taking the old capital market rules
and applying them I think that they need
to figure out how to embrace the power
of Internet distribution the power of
open networks the power of global
investor base is like that's what's
powerful about this and they have to
embrace that if they want to enable the
market benefits if it's just we're gonna
you know try and jam this through the
existing frameworks I don't think it
hardens much yeah yeah so it's sort of
with its essentially like the the
classification of these different asset
types and sort of the specific rules
around them that's the area I think
needs and we're seeing progress on that
in a lot of markets but that's the one
that needs the most work on it what do
you think is gonna happen in the future
what's one thing that maybe other people
aren't expecting or people aren't
talking about as much as you think they
should be yeah I mean it's actually
something we've been talking about for a
long time which is it seems really
obvious to us that in the coming years
that basically payments will go to zero
that the entire business model of
payments will go to zero that we'll be
able to exchange payments with each
other anywhere in the world instantly
with no fees whether it's between people
or people in businesses and that all the
business models that exist around
extracting a toll for receiving a
payment enabling a payment etc will
basically go to zero and that's really
powerful because I think that has to do
with sort of the movement of value in
the global economy and what becomes
possible so you know that that to me is
significant I don't put a specific year
on it but it just strikes us as
something that is is you know inevitably
gonna happen and we see I think what
venmo right there's no fees on venmo and
and you know there's there's
applications that are trying it now it's
closed networks in terms you have to
everything circle pay is free as well
yeah and so I think that that is
probably more likely than not to happen
as you said the hardest part is when
yeah and but I think in particular that
that will be built on interoperable
crypto base rails right so that any
wallet can communicate to any other
wallet and it just works yeah that's
that's what we see happening yeah makes
sense what's the most important book
you've ever read the most important book
I've ever read mm-hmm to really think
about that one really that's the one you
want to think about yeah I've read a lot
of books really interesting I'll get
back to you on that all right I don't
want to give too quick of an answer okay
the one the one caveat I'll say is many
people pick books that they feel like
had a lot of influence on their life
yeah as a proxy for importance the ask
one non crypto question and then you
could ask me a question to end it the
non crypto questions about aliens do you
think that they exist or not yes yes why
sort of mathematical probability my guy
yes
that's my whole argument it's just the
math suggests that it would be near
impossible for the nuttiest yeah all
right
what one question do you have for me
what are you most excited about that's
happening right now in crypto most
excited about there's a lot I think part
of it is we spent a lot of time with
institutional investors just in the
nature of asset management and there's
still a lot of like hey is this even
legal you know what's a blockchain you
know kind of theory what I'll just call
elementary starting point which yeah
which by the way everyone starts there
right so it's just their time they're
behind and yeah but but they'll get
ramped up quickly but the thing that I
see
I think taking hold as a narrative
that's really exciting to me is the
break from like decentralized the world
crypto
you know only etc and much more around
here's products that are being built
here are solutions to those types of
problems here are how this fits into
automation or interview integrates with
other innovative technologies that
you're already familiar with and to me
that is a more macro conversation that
one is easier for them to understand two
is much more believable I think to them
right when they don't understand all the
nuances of the technology but three and
the more important part is there's a
higher likelihood in their mind that
they are going to make money by
investing and that stuff and so what you
see is you're seeing more sophisticated
people come to the table but it's not on
you know hey there's this new utility
token and we're gonna go trade it make a
bunch of money right right it's much
more kind of with you and I probably
think are the sustainable narratives to
get that community involved yeah it'll
take a while but but I think that that
is you know for the long term of growth
of the industry really important that
makes sense you wanna throw a book out
there no no look I really appreciate
takes so much time we've talked quite a
bit and I am a huge fan of what you guys
are doing I think that X bomb you you
were one of the first people that had
what I call a crypto and kumbhak company
that I talked with and you really
believed in everything's gonna get
tokenizer digitized and you've been
playing chess to kind of see that
definitely playing chess which which I
appreciate so I would do this again
absolutely look forward to it thank you
you